this is the first viewing we are doing
monkey bone have you seen this movie uh
years ago
no I don't let you know I have late
onset con funk so I don't know how this
movie will not help you
III really don't know like guarantee
make you worse I don't think I'm gonna
be that this is so it's like a column
rough it's a comedy we don't need to be
funny it will do the work for us
this is monkey bone we did the pool we
don't know you should so it's much
harder be playing with them watching
this L this is Nickelodeon movie written
all over it
yeah I always like to keep pictures of
me and my loved ones right next to the
pains 1 2 3 here go the most I've seen
him in our video saying why he's not
calves anymore action I'm the awkward
artist you can tell you sucker cuz he
has hair covering like when is good luck
I never had any good luck oh poor
good-looking guy with hot girlfriend
with the success looks good
fuck you when Tim Burton attack extra
fun Bridget Fonda has a look on her face
like she just realized what she signed
up oranges like hahahaha you know it's
so touching because their chemistry was
so strong you know we knew them so long
me too me I'm looking all the technical
wizardry I'm like this is amazing how
about this how come they can't get
Brendan Fraser to act
well obviously the style motion artist
working on Brendan Fraser had a few
problems yeah the chemistry those who
have I really do believe I'm watching
two monkeys and it's so nice he has
spent so much time acting along effects
the mummy this Looney tune it never
looked like he's really looking at them
or acting with them I never realize did
this like Brendan Fraser hair if not as
I saw this movie that I realized I did
you look like a sad version a brain guy
from it
okay yeah actually they look like the
little wavy hand things at used car
dealerships if they were no you know
advertised exam bags
I'm layer lay down for a second why did
her head explode this whole movies is
one big why because Betelgeuse
Eraserhead the Saturday morning cartoon
well he's at death's door I'm hoping
this movie will end soon do you think
John Turturro Joe sugg there's going to
be some cool independent film is that
way signed up for this I have no answers
to anything in this movie uh this is
like the worlds of ugly house I am
stunned by how ugly this house is I'll
say this if somebody told me to burn
directed fly of the apes this is the
movie I thought I would get that's an
angle I don't need to see Thank You
monkey bone for dangling Brendan
Fraser's nuts in my face of all the
nightmare fuel things in this movie I
think that's the one I'm going to take
away the most I'm going to guarantee you
by the end of this you will hate Brendan
Fraser as much as I do I'm starting to
think you're right hey look weird
imagery as being that yet alright what
fetish is it this week now call me
poncho via oh of course she came to get
him out because you know again the
connection this movie is all about
connection like Mike fifth to everybody
who is affiliated with this movie space
[Music]
what is going on we just dedicated a
full 60 seconds to carding monkey flush
we don't have to do anything that we
make life choices this is the life we
chose it is our blessing it is also our
curse Candace I'm such a creep you gotta
fuckin eat did you break up with five
boyfriends all i watch is the same ham
script you say a crazy gas out of a
giant pleasure lookin then you say yeah
wait a minute
Doug I'm not sleeping tonight okay this
this really is the stuff of nightmares
I'm a simple person I do an honest day's
work why does everybody make it so hard
for me I'm exists direct to back in the
habit monkey bone come on I'm not that
bad of a comedian
of course it's 2001 you get Chris Kattan
it's just called his movie monkey dump
Oh oh come on a physical comedy a type
of em you know it's funny because I
remember casting myself you know I don't
know Will Ferrell is going to be that
much a movie star he's a little annoying
on SNL for Chris Kattan he's really
funny in S&L he's going to be really
good movies are just completely all the
way around yeah never invest in the
stock market no I still can't see the
Power Ranger thing going anywhere
bringing back she needs me Ninja Turtles
he'll never why go on my little pony
again that make a girl show where was
the male market I'm numb my mind and
body are numb
forget about the naked man with the
purple face how is that joke what your
incredible misguided generosity there's
a speech to the producers of this most
piece of finances I feel like as if you
took egoraptor and removed any sense of
career life like that same crazy vibe
only not funny yeah just nothing funny
is coming up yeah nice two points are
seeing the camera operator shadow Doug
it's not a stop-motion puppet Selleck
doesn't know what to do
because Britain Frazier's character knew
how to do this here I come to inject
something mildly amusing until me in the
land of death
he stole my exit pass all they had left
me was the stinking corpse honestly
maybe Chris Kattan should be discarded
yeah there was more drama there than
anywhere else
yeah I would pay a large sum of money
right now if Terry Gilliam's Monty
Python foot just came down and with and
the movie just stopped Bridget Fonda is
pretending to care in monkeys oh ha ha
even the music's like not quite Danielle
what's really in it the time I remember
the rat race yeah well you're right in
believing off alone hitting the ball
yeah yeah the organ for some reason the
early two-thousands all about organs and
balloons to viber nearly 2,000 Kubo and
the tyq points at least now she knows
how much I love her yeah I never saw a
dose of bring back Chris Kattan I'll
give it to you by the time this was all
said and done I want Chris Kattan over
Brendan Fraser fuck you man don't blame
me blame renovation you know what it is
as soon as this movie is over I'll
probably go back to being indifferent -
OH - but then one another will be with
him is in it I'll be like fuck Brendan
Fraser he's been gun bangs like The
Mummy I don't remember being that great
in that either I remember being passable
but I think that was like early
two-thousands passable I think early
2000 passable is now now bad her I will
say early 2000s she is not held on know
kind of some bad filming I would say
late 90s early 2000 like that dead
terrible Donna mate assumes to hold a
lot of early 90s even like um in the
minute but late 1930 2000s nothing
no dog just put in the best performance
now getting more cat out of him take off
your clothes
hey you know the other hallmark of truly
bad movies this was 90 minutes and that
felt like a three hour long movie yeah
if not the end of several careers it's
like at least the boss cause her highest
retention of other people careers by
you